i think it is clear now that people
became too hopeful about the uprisings
that grip the arab world three years ago
it was it was premature to declare that
the arab spring had arrived
but it is also premature to declare that
we are now in an arab winter
i confess that i myself was probably too
hopeful
in part because of the remarkable
successful transitions that have taken
place in central and eastern europe
in east asia and in south africa and
throughout most of latin america
and even in northern iraq in the region
called kurdistan
that was liberated from saddam hussein's
control in 1991
and has developed positively since then
it will be many years before we know the
true results of this upheaval
but the west and particularly europe has
a very large stake in the outcome and it
is important to remain engaged
libya need not have turned out the way
it is today if the west had engaged
actively after the fall of gaddafi
at that time the population was very
pro-western
because of the assistance the west had
provided during the revolution
and the first two elections in
post-gadhafi libya were victories for
the moderate parties
but instead of providing support to the
new authorities
so that libya would have effective
security forces
or organizing some kind of international
peacekeeping force
the west walked away
and left it to the islamist militias
which are now effectively ruling the
country
it is often been observed correctly
that democracy is about more than just
elections
elections are a means to an end and the
end should be freedom justice and the
rule of law
the desire to be free from tyrannical
rule is a powerful force
as we have been witnessing recently in
the arab world
but simply getting rid of tyrants is not
the same
as embracing the responsibilities
required to make democratic institutions
work
even in the best of circumstances that
is a process that takes time
and all the more so for societies that
have been deformed by decades of abuse
just think about how long it took in
south korea
the armistice that ended the korean war
was signed 61 years ago
for the first 10 years that country was
a wretched corrupt pseudo-democracy
then it was a slightly less corrupt but
brutal dictatorship
it wasn't really until 1981 that you
could begin to see
the signs of what is now a modern
miracle story
we need i think a longer-term
perspective than frankly americans
usually want to take